so I'm going to say something quite
controversial
Star Wars just isn't very good
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a
movie channel
[Music]
now for some portions of the Sci-Fi
world this is a horrific thing to say
but
can't help but believe it I've always
been attractive I've always been a Star
Trek fan first I've never really loved
Star Wars
but I have really enjoyed the
Mandalorian in the last couple of years
I've enjoyed a couple of other things
that Star Wars has done as soon as
there's a Star Wars movie I will go and
watch it
I'm normally quite disappointed but I
will go and watch it
but what really got me thinking about
this was a recent Mandalorian episode
now I've already moaned about this in a
couple of the videos and if you're a
regular sidetracking you'll know
but the Mandalorian episode a couple of
weeks ago with a giant pterodactyl thing
it just didn't make any sense it was
just stupid so I started to think about
is Star Wars actually
just generally stupid now I think most
of us will agree that the most recent
Trilogy had its ups and downs I quite
enjoyed them as films I thought they
were entertaining
but you can question some parts of the
movies and the Big Star Wars fans the
real hardcore Star Wars fans really
don't like big parts of these movies
really the rise of Skywalker for them
and a lot of fans always maybe a movie
too far we could go back to the prequel
series which again has its ups and downs
bits of those movies I really enjoyed
bits of those movers I'm like and large
chunks of those movies I want to forget
but the original trilogy well they were
always great right well I watched them
again recently and all the way through
I'm thinking quite critically about the
movie and I've got to say the dialogue
is awful it's written so badly it's
jerky it kind of wanders off on tangents
sometimes it's red and in some ways
acted like something that just has only
really had one go at it rather than
actually them trying to make a good film
they've had to do a film on a budget
they've had to do it quite quickly and
let's remember as well actually that
George Lucas had so little confidence in
this movie that instead of going to the
premiere of Star Wars A New Hope he went
on holiday with Steven Spielberg and
they came up with the Indiana Jones
storyline idea
but why was Star Wars popular why is it
popular if it's actually just not very
well written Etc well lightsabers are
cool the Millennium Falcon is cool the
music is cool
um and generally you know things like
the Stormtroopers uniforms and things
like this it's all really cool there are
lots of bits in there that they got to
make toys out of that are really really
cool now I briefly mentioned there that
I'm not a massive fan of the story well
again for a couple of reasons
there are some giant leaps of logic when
it comes to Star Wars the Stormtroopers
who are professional soldiers can't hit
the side of a barn that's a bit of a
problem you have Luke Skywalker who has
been a farmer on a moisture Farm his
whole life jumping straight into an
X-Wing and becoming an excellent pilot
now we actually had this with space
Jesus Anakin from the um prequel Series
where he jumped straight into one of
those he actually he's a really cool
fighter but he jumped straight into that
and he's again a really cool amazing
fighter immediately at the age of like
four
it doesn't really make sense but at
least they argued there that he'd been
pod racing his whole life now there have
been some background stuff with Luke
saying that he was also a Pod racer and
that maybe they actually put like
training wheels on the X-Wing either in
a way that they put some sort of
computer program on everything to make
it easier to fly for him but look we get
this in Star Trek all the time as well
that they make a mistake in the writing
or something doesn't make sense and the
fans have to then make up really
intelligent reasons to make it make
sense it frustrates the hell out of me
if something doesn't make sense it
doesn't make sense and that's the end of
it and in Star Wars there are loads of
things that just don't make sense and
it's not just the original series
the last movie so the rise of Skywalker
I don't know why she called herself
Skywalker at the end don't know where
that came from but hey she did she felt
you know a connection with Luke and she
wanted to forget her Palpatine passed
but anyway they did that the massive
star Fleet that Palpatine then had on
that planet hidden under the clouds how
the hell did he make that Fleet there
was thousands of ships one basically one
for each planet it was it was ready to
wipe out the entire universe if
necessary
Star Destroyers with Planet killing
capabilities now I've heard other people
say that while he was building that
Fleet for ages so back even when he was
still the emperor so if that's right why
was he building the Death Star the Death
Star was massive
it would have required enormous
resources
the Star Destroyer with the planet
killing gun underneath far less so what
people basically argued is that when he
was building an athlete while he was
building the best style or the second
death star well that that makes no sense
the other option is after he was thrown
into the core by Darth Vader he
retreated to that planet and then
started to build that Fleet so again
this Emperor has massive resources
but still even though he had that Fleet
and it was already and manned by the way
he was just waiting and talking about
the massive resources that were required
to build this Fleet think about the
Empire I'm not sure they're the bad guys
now the Rebellion has no resources a
bunch of the people that actually work
for a criminals if you think Han Solo
criminal he's a drug dealer basically or
a Smuggler you know criminal
um they've got no ships they've got
ships that are basically barely work in
the original Star Wars movie that
Rebellion set there was considered sort
of thing the only one the Death Star
goes there destroys that planet that's
the end of the Rebellion now actually in
the Andor series we got to see that
actually there was lots and lots of
cells of the Rebellion they were set up
like a terrorist organization which does
to be fair make sense because if you
lose one cell the other cells aren't
compromised now some point between Andor
and the end of New Hope You could argue
that maybe several of other cells were
were destroyed
but that's not a very long time frame
we're only actually talking a few months
so
that doesn't again really make sense
and it is actually a big problem between
and or and New Hope that the rebellion
was sort of Rewritten and reimagined
because again as I said they have these
sort of like Terror cells rather than
the one organized Rebellion base that we
saw in New Hope but the Empire is way
better funded way better supported
apparently because they've got way more
resources and they can build
star destroying planets they can build
two death stars they can build this
entire fleet of Star Destroyers they
built an entire fleet of Star Destroyers
to police the Galaxy after the end of
the Republic
people weren't writing in the streets
when the Empire took over they were
quietly getting amongst their work now
they might have been living in fear in
lots of parts of the Galaxy but on the
whole the Galaxy seemed to just get on
with it the people who join the
rebellion and there weren't many of them
we're the only ones that seem to be
unhappy now I know this is maybe a
metaphor between big government and
small government and you know like
Freedom Fighters Etc but at the end of
the day for the Empire to really be the
bad guys they have to be the bad guys
and if we live in a universe of
democracy which is apparently what the
Republic was then the Empire seems to be
more popular
nobody voted for the Rebellion they
people just decided to do it
so as I say I'm not sure the rebellion
of the good guys and the Empire of the
bad guys because the people seem to be
quite happy with the Empire there is
also the storyline for the zuhan bong
this enemy that is going to come from
outside of the Galaxy and attack the
Republic and actually the Empire would
have been far more capable in the
Republic in actually defending the
people of the Galaxy against that threat
so perhaps in a later series we're
actually going to see that Palpatine was
actually just trying to defend people
against this greater threat I actually
quite like that storyline idea and I
hope that's where they're going with the
current crop of Star Wars it does seem
to be though that the only good bits of
Star Wars is maybe some of the animated
stuff maybe some of the comics and maybe
some of the novels the actual stuff
we've had on screen including the
original trilogy is actually not that
good
this seems to be a franchise built on
the toys rather than a franchise built
an actual quality television
now I actually put a poll on now this
was a bit of a cheeky pole but it was
basically said look if you want Stargate
to come back you have to lose either
Star Wars or Star Trek now I thought
that would be pretty 50 50 because the
people that love Trek love Trek the
people that love Star Wars love Star
Wars so I put the question just for fun
for Stargate to come back one has to die
which would you choose Star Trek or Star
Wars we had 1 900 votes at the point of
recording 27 said Star Trek must die in
73 said Star Wars Must Die
three-quarters of people are going yeah
full of Star Wars down the loo
Star Trek is the one we want to keep but
it does just sort of show that if you're
a Sci-Fi fan Star Wars isn't really for
you
but Star Wars isn't sci-fi the people
shout it's science fantasy
that's just a cop-out that's just
basically a way of saying that yes we
know this doesn't make sense but don't
worry about it it's fantasy
now the other way of looking at it is a
Space Opera have you ever actually sat
through an opera in space or not it's
boring and that's the other thing I
would say about Star Wars It's really
slow and quite boring at times
Now give me a good Star Trek episode any
day of the week
I've heard
this already you you cannot dog on Star
Wars anymore this
this it's absurd
no no no I I can dog on it because it's
it Harris we've had this description for
me it's rubbish
it's all rubbish it's it's it's badly
written it's rubbish
it is pure joy encapsulated in space
fantasy and it couldn't be better I I
tell you what if you disagree with me
why don't you do a video explaining it
and then everybody at home can
understand why you're wrong
fine I'll do it I'll do it I'll take the
challenge so there we go the challenge
is set Harris is going to come back with
a video explaining to me why I'm wrong
so guys why don't you get in the
comments tell me why I'm wrong tell me
why you think Star Wars actually is
awesome or actually why Star Wars is as
I say
kind of crap
I'd love to know exactly what you're
thinking
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps out and you
will never miss any of our newest videos
also you can check out the description
there's a loads of related Side Track
stuff including Facebook link uh Discord
server where people go and have a nice
chat and things like our Twitter account
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where most of our new
videos appear first and for a small
contribution each month you can get to
see them first and without the adverts
it also really helps the channel
as always guys please stay safe I'll see
you next time
[Music]